What do you love about this country?
I love that it's small, and
I love that we're existing,
and we have to be proud
that we have a country.
Kyrgyzstan aka the Kyrgyz Republic,
is perhaps not the most
obvious place to visit
for a show about technology.
Kyrgyzstan used to be
part of the Soviet Union,
so it has lots of Soviet
stuff laying around.
Soviet government
buildings, Soviet sculptures
Soviet theme parks with an extra
dollop of wintery dystopia.
There's even Vlad, the dead one,
fresh from a snowball fight.
In the winter, the capital city of Bishkek
is, well, it's bleak.
Coal and trash fires
envelope the city in smog.
It's grim, then beautiful, then grim,
then beautiful all over
again, and also kind of weird.
The city's circus, for example,
takes place inside a decaying UFO.
Now I'm not going to dazzle you
with the usual robots and DNA editing.
The story here is about
a fragile democracy
trying to find its place
in the modern world.
Our people were so courageous
to go and do the revolution
and fight for it.
I saw it.
They were shooting people.
It's about a landlocked nation,
one with very few natural resources,
hoping to gen up a tech
industry on the fly.
We are limited by resources.
I like it that we don't
have the resources.
Otherwise, if everything would
be okay, so we would be lazy.
Kyrgyzstan, it turns
out, really wants to sell
the rest of the world on
its software engineers
and its internet creators.
And on that score, they've had
at least one major success.
Believe it or not, some of the most
popular videos on YouTube are cooked up
right here in Bishkek.
Hello world!
We are D Billions!
Hello, welcome to D Billions home.
Let me show you around.
Here we make some shoots for our channel.
This is the actors' room.
Hello guys.
Hello!
Hey!
Animation studio A, animation studio B.
Welcome to audio recording studio.
What up, guys?
Hello.
I think all our singers are here.
Aman, who got 2.5 billion views.
Everybody knows these guys.
Everybody knows these guys in Kyrgyzstan.
To be the part of this team,
that's a dream team, really.
I'm not going to lie, I
came here in small part
to kind of make fun of D Billions.
♪ Chicky cha-cha, boom-boom ♪
♪ La, la, la, la, la ♪
It's a kid show on YouTube,
and if you have spawn,
there's a very good chance
they have consumed some of this.
♪ Mommy, mommy, mommy, mommy, mommy ♪
It's not exactly high art.
Some people might even call
it villainous ear poison.
♪ Shake, shake move your body ♪
But whatever you think
doesn't really matter.
They get the views, the billions
and the billions of them.
This is our diamond button.
First in Central Asia.
This is our trophy.
We achieve it that we got
10 million.
Subscribers.
How did a 50 person outfit
in a country many people
have never heard of
achieve this kind of success?
To find out, I sat down with the founders.
Husband and wife team,
Ernist and Cholponay.
Ernist is a producer, and
Cholponay is a singer and actor.
I do this for a living,
you know, research people.
There's just, there's like
nothing about you guys.
The Western press has not sort of
It's going to be first interview.
This one.
This.
Right, okay, that's what I was wondering.
Because we don't like it.
We just want to work.
For people who have never
seen any of your shows before,
can you explain what D Billions is?
D Billions is a group
focusing only on kids songs.
We have 13 channels in
different languages.
And the two of you, you're
a husband and wife, right?
We grew up together studying
in theatre children's choir.
That's called Ak Shoola.
And we took part in many
international kids festivals,
and when Ernist was 15 years
old, he created teenage group.
We were rapping, break dancing,
singing classic songs, pop songs.
That was the beginning of D Billions.
We had all the experience we
needed to work on YouTube.
We have four music videos
with billion views,
and in addition, when we first
saw the "Baby Shark" video,
it already had billion views.
Ernist said, "I also
can make such a song."
♪ Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy ♪
♪ So yummy ♪
Here's how that went.
♪ Yummy, yummy, so yummy ♪
So what's the secret sauce?
♪ I like it, I like it ♪
I think kids loves the
rhythm of this song.
Like, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
♪ So yummy ♪
♪ Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy ♪
Kids loves to repeat it, and
there is one more secret.
It's in minimalism.
♪ I am a triangle ♪
Every song has a goal to
teach one or two words
without overloading kids' attention.
Unicorn.
Statistics show that the
most minimalist songs
break all records.
You heard her, internet creators.
Now go get those D Billions.
Okay, so maybe it's not the
most mind improving content,
but it is some kind of modern phenomenon.
D Billions is just one of a dozen channels
this company is feeding, and
their success has allowed them
to recruit the best
singers, graphic artists,
and composers in the country
all to pump out videos at hyper speed.
This is a very American, crass question.
How big is the business in
terms of not just viewers,
but it must be like huge
in terms of revenue?
Perhaps because we are a Kyrgyz company,
we are on the list of high earning companies in Kyrgyzstan.
But if you compare our revenue with American companies,
we would be one of the smallest.
Ernist didn't want to
get into exact numbers.
So let's take a wild guess, shall we?
Other YouTube kids channels
with similar view counts
have reported earning millions,
even tens of millions of dollars per year.
D Billions might take a hit
from having many viewers outside the US,
but it's safe to say they're
doing well for themselves.
The whole enterprise gets a boost
from the Kyrgyz government
and industry too
through a programme called IT Park.
The hope is to conjure a
flourishing Kyrgyz tech industry
out of thin air by giving
companies like D Billions
massive tax breaks.
Participants of IT Park, they are free
from all taxes except 1% income tax,
and we are participants of IT Park,
and that's been a great
support from our government.
But the picture wasn't always
this rosy for D Billions.
Virality might come easy to these folks,
but trying to get paid on YouTube,
that's a whole other thing.
Before the D Billions, there
was a channel AWA, A-W-A.
We were working there, and
we got one hit cartoon.
It was so 42 million views.
That was for us, phenomenal.
I would kill for 42 million views
42 million views, oh my God.
That was unbelievable.
That moment was for us like phenomenal.
They said like, "Wow, we sold 42 million."
But then
Then they cut all the
monetization of A-W-A.
And we didn't get any
money from it.
YouTube cut the money?
Yes. Yes.
Why?
Demonetization.
We break some terms.
We didn't know some rules.
That's why.
And nobody would tell us all the rules
what we should to do.
We were working two years just for free.
Yeah, yeah.
It was very hard time.
We were starving.
So it was it sounds like
it was sort of frightening, like, scary.
Yeah, it was.
So you were a couple with a young child,
and taking all this financial risk.
Money, no.
Belief. Talk of belief.
I may have come here to tease,
but my time with the D
Billions crew left me amazed.
The vibe at the office
was more hardworking,
fun-loving family than more
unfilled influencer mansion,
and there was creativity everywhere.
Boom-Boom can play
basically any instrument.
Ernist and Cholponay have
an obvious eye for talent,
and a gift for reading
the whims of the internet.
And instead of staff meetings,
D Billions has all hands
campfire sing-alongs.
This was just a small warm-up
before shooting our cartoons.
Of course, to really
understand D Billions,
I had to become D Billions.
Behold, American Daddy.
Saviour of YouTube children.
I'm about to be a superhero
in a D Billions video.
Go to Kyrgyzstan, and
amazing things happen.
When you do it at the end,
just you can do like flying up.
Okay.
Same, but with this side.
I'm super dad, people are in trouble.
I must save them.
You ready?
Yeah.
Camera. Action.
Help, help, help!
Where are they?
It's okay, now we're on the ground.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Thank you for teaching
me to be a superhero.
Now I want to see the professionals work.
D Billions told me they would
animate this all together
into something amazing.
In the meantime, allow me to tell you
some less kid-friendly things
about the Kyrgyz Republic.
The country became part of
the Soviet Union in 1936.
The Soviets did their best to try and turn
a rural, very poor society
into something else.
Mostly, they poured money into Bishkek,
and the buildings and people followed.
The Kyrgyz Republic arrived in 1991.
It's a democracy, but not
exactly a grade A democracy.
Votes can be bought and sold,
and there's a not
infrequent number of coups.
It's a Muslim nation, but
religion does not feel
like it takes centre stage here.
Today, the country's ties
to Russia remain strong
with cheap energy meant to
keep the Kyrgyz people sweet.
It's a precarious position,
and one from which many people
here hope to break free.
D Billions is meant to represent
what Kyrgyzstan can be in the future.
A more modern nation, one full
of creativity and expression.
But this journey is not always smooth.
Take for example the story of Zere.
One of the most famous
singers in the country.
She's YouTube famous, too,
but in a very different way.
I started thinking, okay,
I should do something big,
something about women's rights
because that's what I care
about deeply right now.
And so I just started writing a song,
I made my friends listen to it.
They said maybe I should do a video,
so that's how it all started.
And you did go viral.
I did, I guess. Yeah.
When you did this song,
obviously the lyrics of the song
brought up a lot of issues
that some people were,
you know, happy, very happy
to see being discussed openly,
and obviously a lot of
people were less happy.
And then in the video, I
think you were wearing a bra
and people were, you know, what happened?
So the reaction was basically enormous.
I thought that the provoking stuff
would be seeing like a girl in hijab
besides a girl in a bikini, and, you know,
all of that diversity that
has never been seen before.
But the provoking thing was something
that I literally just
decided like, in a second.
You know, I was like, "Okay,
I'm going to look like this."
That was the main trigger for
the whole dialogue to start.
I was sort of ready for some backlash,
sort of ready for some, you know,
bullying or stuff like that,
but it always seems easy in theory.
You got death threats.
I did, I did get death threats,
and there were a lot of them actually.
Do you still face a lot of the pushback,
or has it sort of died down?
Like, is it uncomfortable for
you to walk down the street?
I wouldn't say I'm comfortable
walking in any street.
It was a terrible example.
Yeah, 'cause I've heard
you sing about this, yeah.
Yeah, like, on top of the cat calling
and everything that you get as a woman,
if you're also like a feminist
who was naked on the
screen and all of that,
that also puts other layers, you know?
Part of the reaction was
how you were dressed.
Part of the reaction was the
things you were talking about,
and the stories I read just said
these are things that
aren't often discussed.
Well, I think they were always discussed,
not just collectively like that, you know?
Not through one thing that
everyone has an opinion on.
How would you describe the
issues that women face broadly?
For an average woman in
Kyrgyzstan, it's hard everywhere.
Like, at home, in the streets,
you can literally get kidnapped,
like, and made a bride.
You're supposed to marry
your rapist basically
when you get kidnapped as a bride.
Unfortunately, it still happens.
It doesn't happen as often
as, you know, before,
but still, it does happen.
Kyrgyzstan is bizarrely
famous, or rather infamous,
for the practise of bride kidnapping.
Women are grabbed off the
streets and forced into marriage.
No one in the country seems to agree
on how prevalent this is.
Although in my short time here,
I met several women who told
me they had been kidnapped,
or had family members
who had been kidnapped.
The practise was only made
illegal a couple of years ago,
and it's questionable how much
the law is actually enforced.
If a woman gets harassed,
beaten up at home,
assaulted in the streets,
and a lot of other stuff
that can happen to women,
you go to the police,
police is never going to help you.
I've never seen one case in my life
where the police was actually
helpful in these issues.
We asked the Kyrgyz government
to comment on all this,
but we never heard back.
And can I just add that I'm
saying this absolutely like,
being in love with this
country, you know what I mean?
Like, it's not like I am
complaining, and like,
trying to go somewhere.
No, like, I want to be among those people
who try and make Kyrgyzstan at least like,
a safer place to live.
Is there a sense that things are changing?
If I look, there was a female
president relatively recently.
I think the first in Central Asia.
Is there a sense that
things are changing or like,
do you feel like it's just
the same as it ever was?
I myself, I'm very amazed and inspired
by a lot of what women do in our country.
And you're right, like
relatively speaking,
in the region where we are,
we have some better stuff going on,
but that's relatively speaking, you know?
There's a lot still to do for sure.
The next night, the D Billions crew
invites me out for an evening
of revelry, Bishkek style.
♪ Everything's going to be all right ♪
After getting good and
tipsy on Kyrgyz lager,
it's time for the grand unveiling.
This is as exciting as it gets.
I get to see myself as USA
Super Daddy on a big screen.
There's every chance D
Billions is a one-off
that got lucky hitting
the internet just right.
But Kyrgyzstan is betting and
hoping that this is the start
of a full on tech revolution
within the country.
The woman riding this
horse so majestically
is Tavita.
And she symbolizes a lot about Kyrgyzstan.
This is a place where the
people take great pride
in the natural beauty of the country.
It's also a place fond of its
traditions, in nomadic past.
Tavita though,
is also part of something
new and different here.
When not galloping, she's coding.
She is part of a wave of
thousands of young Kyrgyz students
being trained as software engineers.
The hope is to create a
homegrown Kyrgyz tech industry,
which can serve as an economic engine
to power the country's future.
Naturally, I went to a fine-dining yurt
with Tavita and her sister Avigail,
who also works in tech
to learn more about their experiences.
- What do we have?
- So different kinds of bread and borsok.
It's like fried dough.
- [Ashlee] Smells good.
- Yeah, these are different types of meat.
And horse meat as well.
- Okay. How did the two of
you get into technology?
'Cause you both have interest, obviously.
- So my sister first started
interested in IT sphere
And after that she said she recommended me
to get into the IT industry.
- What have you been doing?
- Frontend development.
- Okay.
I'm the middle of front-end developer.
- What kind of company?
Meanwhile, Tavita's
sister Avigail has a job
telling the world about
Kyrgyzstan's coding efforts.
- You want to work with
American tech communities,
businesses, you have to
provide really high quality.
So our pitch was that we've been working,
we are experienced,
we already have clients and
also cheap infrastructure,
like electricity and also demographics.
Very young people, there
are a lot of talents.
And I think that this is because
there was like huge focus on mathematics.
And people are being just very motivated.
- It's a pretty convincing story,
which is good because the stakes are high.
Kyrgyzstan has a nearly 30% poverty rate.
And a per capita GDP
only a mother could love.
With few natural resources to mine,
and little in the way of big industry,
it needs to look outside.
The goal for the country is
to have how many programmers?
- 50,000.
- 50,000, by?
- 2030.
- By 2030.
- Yeah.
- And what number are we at today?
- I think we're around 7,000.
- 7,000. All right.
So you're part of like the 7,000 then?
- Yeah.
- To build a 50,000-strong software army,
you need boot camps.
This is the headquarters of Codify,
one of several companies in
Bishkek with coding programs
for people of all ages.
It was started by Dinara Ruslan.
She grew up here, moved to Silicon Valley,
and then came back with the hopes
of building a tech giant in Bishkek.
- I was doing IT project
product management
and I always needed project managers.
But I couldn't get them
because no one actually prepares
them here in Central Asia.
So then I started teaching it myself.
- You have this fascinating background
because you worked in Silicon
Valley and technology,
I saw you worked in Iowa in technology.
And I mean, for you to
come back and do this,
you must have some hope that you can help
in this push in Kyrgyzstan
to sort of modernize.
Or is this, you just saw
a business opportunity?
- Like when you grow up in a family
where you like low
income, low-class family,
you just don't think on like,
"Oh my God, I'm going to help my country."
No, you think like,
"Oh my god, what I'm
going to eat tomorrow?"
I'm going to survive, you know?
So I'm going to lie if I say,
"Oh, I want to help the country, whatever.
No, I grow up thinking that
I have to become someone."
- Dinara did become someone.
A Product Manager at Wells Fargo.
And tasted the decadent delights
that the magical land of
California has to offer.
- You get a job and you are making money.
And you start going to mall on weekends,
and then to cinema on
Fridays with your friends.
And then you think,
"Oh my God, this is the life,
this is the American dream."
I was taking Uber and then I was buying
and ordering this weekly vegetables
to be delivered to my house.
But then, it snapped. It was May, 2016.
I was thinking,
"I haven't seen my family and
my country in four years."
I just decided, took a vacation,
and then I was supposed
to leave to go back to my,
another dream job in California.
And then I got this job
offer from local startup.
- Dinara never left.
And eventually started
several companies of her own.
She might frame her decision
to stay as strictly business.
But her coding school is very much part
of the national project.
Preparing little ones to participate
in the economy of the future.
My name is Aybike, I’m seven years old
and I’m studying Scratch.
- My name is Lea, I'm
15 and I'm study HTML.
- My name is Zoldana. I'm 16 years old.
And I'm studying here JavaScript.
- And Dinara takes particular pride
in helping young women become tech-savvy.
- If you look at the IT scene,
if you even look at my
office, 80% is the girls.
You're going to see
other startup founders.
They're also like female founders.
So you'll see that the
Kyrgyzstan is different.
- It's a happy fact
that women have a strong presence
in the Kyrgyz tech scene.
I met a good number of
female leaders and engineers
during my visit to Bishkek.
They're not hard to find.
But the picture is complicated.
Kyrgyz society can be
brutally chauvinistic.
Women are often expected to
take on traditional roles
in the home, not to learn
to code, or pursue a career.
- Society's opinion will affect
you if you think about it.
If you don't think about it,
then just study and do your job.
Like who cares what that person is saying,
that you can or cannot do?
If you think,
- Yeah.
- If you believe that
you can do something,
that's all that matters.
- When it comes to women's issues,
Dinara is quick to accentuate the positive
and insist that anyone can make it.
But that's no surprise
coming from a self-made woman
who founded three
companies by the age of 30.
If anyone can bootstrap
Kyrgyzstan into tech prosperity,
it's people like her.
- Do we have a future?
Yes. Is it bright one?
I think yes, because I'm a dreamer.
I actually have a dream
to build a first unicorn
out of Kyrgyzstan and Central Asia.
Hopefully Codify.
- I for one, wouldn't bet against her.
"Don't go to Kyrgyzstan in
the winter," they told me.
"It's gray and polluted.
It's a horrible time to visit," they said.
- But then, how else
would I have seen this?
It's Alaman Ulak time,
in a Kyrgyz village about
three hours from Bishkek.
You get a goat, the goat suffers.
And then you have what amounts to a ball.
And whoever has the ball is under attack.
The goal on this day
is to get the goat back
to your village first.
Then you get to eat the goat.
And it's been well tenderized.
Whoa!
Clearly this is a place that
keeps its traditions alive.
At least the super epic ones.
But Kyrgyzstan's future is
taking shape out here too.
That's thanks in large part to
this extremely cheerful man,
Tolondu Toichubaev.
Tolondu made a fortune
in the biotech business
all over the world.
Then came back to Kyrgyzstan,
in hopes of making his homeland
more prosperous and free.
He's set out to build a series of schools
throughout the country.
The first one came to life
here, where he grew up.
We're going to your school?
- Yeah. It's a first school.
We built it in 10 years ago, 11 years ago.
First school.
- And how close is it to
where you went to school?
- I grew up on the
village, on this village.
But I always been
walking from this village
until that village.
- Okay.
- Two miles every day.
- You walked two miles in the snow?
- In the snow. It was..
- Classic.
- Yeah. The classical story.
- Here we go.
Oh wow, it's huge!
- It's huge. It's huge.
- It's music time, it looks like
- It's always the best time, music time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one, it's all local flora and fauna.
- Okay.
- Which we have in Kyrgyzstan.
Tolondu wants his schools
to foster creative
and critical thinking,
in contrast to what he sees
as the more rote instruction
at government schools.
He's built 15 schools across Kyrgyzstan,
and plans to build 15 more.
He's funded much of
this operation to date.
But hopes the schools will
soon be self-sustaining.
Tell me about your whole vision
of how you started the schools
and where you want to take it?
- It's a simple what for you need money.
Money should work for something.
So that's why I had the first idea
that I have to have 10 schools.
I will have a $1 million
for one school every year.
And then I said,
"Okay, I now I have to find a business
which will generate enough money
to build the schools for me."
- Tolondu was a teenager
when the Soviet Union collapsed in 1991,
leaving Kyrgyzstan's economy in shambles.
He was able to get a
medical degree in Bishkek,
then took a job in the government.
But quickly found himself at a dead end.
- For me, it was on front
of mind, it's two way.
Either I have to corrupted.
Either I have to poor.
- So you thought if you
stay at the government,
and you just do your
job and you do it well,
you're going to be poor.
'Cause I think it's
- Yeah, because my
salary was, at that time,
that time it was 50 bucks a month.
So I decided to start my business.
But while I am from the village
and I don't have relatives
who can help for me.
And so I decided that what I can do,
I can sell my brain only.
And so I decided to build
a consulting company.
- He started a medical
diagnostic business.
And who wouldn't buy medical
diagnostics from this man?
Tell me everywhere you
have a diagnostic lab now.
It's Kazakhstan, Kyrgyzstan, Ukraine.
- Yeah, Ukraine, Russia.
Before, was in China, in Vietnam.
- This has turned into a massive business.
- Yes, and kind of enough
to build the schools.
- [Ashlee] Yeah. Yeah.
You want all these kids
to be able to participate
in the global economy.
- Absolutely. So that's why
it's 80% of our students,
out of our schools entering
the best universities in US
and Europe.
- That doesn't bother you
that they're going overseas,
you feel like?
- I believe that some of
them, they will stay there,
in US or Europe.
But I believe some of
them, they will come back.
And I believe that critical
mass of that people
will change country.
Hi guys. How are you doing?
We cool guys?
Would be nice just to,
can we join for you for
discussion, for your debate?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Good, good.
- Here is this...
- We happened to visit Tolondu's school
on a very special day.
We've got a debate going on.
It's 10th and 11th
grade students, I think.
- Yeah.
- And it's kind of, should
art be taught in schools?
And we've got pro arts
and we've got the cruel anti-art people.
- Art brings harmony and
beauty into a person's life.
- Science given the
students the opportunity
to better understand
how and why things work.
- I sat back and watched
the free thinking fly.
- Learning to read music
helped to develop our brain
and to increase our mental capacity.
- It was kind of like a scene
from "Dead Poets Society."
If the students were also
being stunningly eloquent
in their third language.
- Providing the arts adequately
as part of the curriculum cost extra money
in teacher time and resources.
- I urge you to support our position
that art isn't essential
to be in the school to
- I think it's would be
nice just to understand,
do you Opposition or in
Parliament, actually?
- Well, I thought both
sides made good arguments.
I am a reporter and a TV maker
who covers science and technology,
but I'm making art about
science and technology.
So I think we can't have them split.
We have to have both together.
- From my position, I
take the simple things.
Do you know what this mean, guys?
I believe that 75% of this is art.
And mostly I think it's
without linkage between art
and the technology,
you couldn't create new,
exciting things in the world.
- I'm trying to know
how optimistic to feel
about Kyrgyzstan.
It still seems like you have some
of these fundamental problems,
that there's limited natural resources.
There's people like you that
are trying to educate students
and there's people pushing in technology.
But it's going to be a long journey.
- Yeah, it can be a long journey.
- Yeah.
- But we are lucky that we
don't have mineral resources.
We are lucky that we don't have oils.
- Okay.
- And all of situations
pushing us to think more,
what we can do, what we can achieve.
Because I see some kind
of countries who has,
for example, oil.
And as they becoming lazy.
Because it's easy, take
oil and sell it, it's easy.
If you depends only on the human being,
then it's a question, then
they're starting to move.
- Back in Bishkek,
there are signs that many things
in Kyrgyzstan are changing.
And changing for the better.
This building may not look
like much from the outside.
In fact, it looks pretty terrible.
But on the inside,
there's a group of young
women aiming for the stars.
Or at least, for low Earth orbit.
Kyzzhibek here is the Director
of the Kyrgyz Space Program,
aka, the Satellite
Building School for Girls.
The goal is to make
Kyrgyzstan's first satellite
and fly it into space.
- Unfortunately, with
the collapse of the USSR,
we did not have any space
projects or space agencies.
So that's what we are trying
to do, to revive this industry.
And we are also doing
it with a team of girls,
because we really want
to convey our message
that we need more girls
in STEM, in technology.
So this is the first
satellite in our country
that we brought here.
- The big reveal.
- This is a prototype of a CubeSat.
Of course you don't
want this to go to space
because it's not really protected
and doesn't use the materials
that are able to endure space.
But it's a great model to learn with
- Yeah. And if I can
nerd out for a second,
'cause I'm a satellite nerd.
Not too long ago, if you
wanted to build a satellite,
you had to do everything from scratch.
It was very expensive.
It was like reinventing
the wheel every time.
And then a couple universities
in the United States
came up with this CubeSat idea
to sort of standardize the shape,
some of the components you could put in.
And so this is just a really cool thing,
where it gives you this huge headstart.
It pulls the price down.
- Yes, that's totally true.
Even 30 years ago,
we would not have imagined
we would be able to do that.
And now you can see space is successful.
It's open to everyone.
- Yeah.
- That's great.
- We totally take a
nation state to-do list.
- Yeah, so basically,
the idea was to understand
what components does the
CubeSat consist from?
How they communicate with each other,
how they work with each other,
and try to connect them to our own sensor.
When people ask us,
"What is your satellite
going to do in space?"
- Yeah.
- We say,
"It doesn't matter what
it is doing in space.
It's going to be the first
satellite of our country."
- Yeah.
- In space.
We will have some space heritage.
We'll have knowledge, expertise,
that we can transfer to an
educational institution,
to promote space and
to revive the industry.
- If ever there's been a time
when this plan could work, it's right now.
With tiny starter satellites
available for purchase
and commercial rocket companies
selling ever more affordable
flights into orbit.
There's never been an easier time
to get your gadget off-planet.
That doesn't mean it's trivial.
Kyzzhibek still needs to
raise a few hundred grand
to get a spot on a SpaceX
or a Rocket Lab launch.
And it's always a dicey proposition,
whether these things will actually work,
once they're exposed to the void.
So you need some money and you
still have some work to do.
I mean, do you have a goal
date to fly the satellite?
- Oh, that's the toughest question.
I tell people that if I ever paid a dollar
each time a person asks me this question.
- We have to embrace
what people do in space,
which is you just announce something,
and they're just really late.
So that's what everybody does.
That's the, it's the beauty of aerospace.
- Yes, yes, I know.
- If the team succeeds,
they'll give birth to a
Kyrgyz space industry.
Even more important,
they'll send an undeniable
message to the haters and losers
who don't think women have a place
in Kyrgyzstan's tech future.
- They see, I think women
of my kind, like a danger.
They're scared.
- Yeah.
And they say, you have,
I'm not sure that it's
supposed to be on the camera.
Like you have balls.
Why do you compare me to a man?
Why am I supposed to have
balls? I don't like this trend.
- Yeah.
- If you are a cool woman,
you're compared to a man.
Therefore, I think, for us as role models,
it's not only important to
become role models in STEM,
but also in personal life.
Saying that, "I'm a strong
woman, I can do everything."
And that's why my personal
life and my career,
I can excel in them.
They can both work out together.
- I didn't have a lot of
expectations coming here.
But even if you just spend
a week in Kyrgyzstan,
there's some things that
become totally obvious.
It's a beautiful country.
The people must be among the
most generous in the world.
And it's a country that's
fragile, in a delicate state,
but one where there's a
lot of hope for the future.
And anything could happen.